I'm really sorry about my family they're
so annoying it seemed pretty great to me
Oh looks can be deceiving right hmm so
you come into the fireworks with us
tonight or what well I kind told the
guys I'd hang out with them too
let's hope I survive it alone then
winds blow nice today
yeah
hey duo cannot for what hey guys hi
grace
hey Timmy hey hunter you uh teaching our
boy the ways of the world who shut up
sorry thanks
hey you just say sorry to her man
because you're supposed to meet up with
us like three hours ago that's cool
Conrad
you want to hang out with a bunch of
children go right ahead see you later
what do you say if I told you you were
gonna be my first love she totally wants
you man bothers likes my body anyway
I feel different around you than I do
with the guys cut hopes up I can be
myself more
what happened at Makani there ain't no
change in their history is all still
there
sleepless me here what don't be stupid
just sleep next to no real man juices
some chick his best buds
all I want to do is just be a kid don't
forget that part of you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you wake up one day and you realize that
your parents are just as crazy and
messed up as we are hi grace you uh
teaching our boy the ways of the world
shut up you shut up are you two gonna
leave yes we were just getting started
and I'd really like to get back to it
[Music]
you